well Democrats may have an intention of
resisting Donald Trump on a lot of
issues in his first hundred days and in
the first two years of his
administration they don't have the votes
to effectively stop him at least not in
the House of Representatives where
they're at one of the low points they've
had since 1928 they have enough votes in
the Senate to sustain a filibuster but
as the outgoing Democratic Leader Harry
Reid pointed out he changed the
filibuster rules for lower federal court
nominations and there's nothing to stop
the Republican majority from changing
them for Supreme Court nominations which
one will be on tap or on other issues I
think an interesting point is whether or
not the Republicans can move ahead on
immigration and can peel off some
Democratic votes here and also on
infrastructure issues the Democrats say
they want to build more infrastructure
so does the president-elect will some of
them go along with the package that he
will put in that might get away with
certain obstructions we'll see
you